this is mound house a small town outside
Carson City in rural Nevada there's
almost nothing here but desert desert
and prostitutes here at the Moonlite
bunnyranch we love to serve everybody
from fetishes the girl next door to porn
star parties to empathise parties to
divorce parties here we don't judge so
we open up to anybody and everybody and
we're here to have fun and make you [ __ ]
they're doing it because they want to
because we don't want to work for what
society pays or they want to have a job
where they can make a good amount of
money in a short period of time and then
get lay on the beach in Hawaii or work
on their studies or their career and
music or dancing or whatever they want
to do Dennis HOF runs the Moonlite
bunnyranch
a world-famous brothel featured in HBO's
cathouse series isolated counties in
rural Nevada are the only places in
America where prostitution is legal and
regulated prostitution cannot be in a
county that has more than 400,000 people
then eliminates Las Vegas and eliminates
Reno in Las Vegas
the sheriff has just entered his 500
girl in his little black book of girls
so arrested working with HIV so what
happens in Vegas that goes back to Des
Moines LA San Francisco all over the
country in 32 years mandatory testing
every girl every week never a case HIV
when you legalize it it takes it takes
the STDs out of it it takes the drugs
out of it the difference between working
in a legal place to working as illegal
prostitute is number one here at the
brothel we have a panic button out there
on the outside you have no protection at
all the main thing that would make my
life safer would be decriminalization
this la-based sex worker asked to be
identified as Holly
she has no boss or pimp and gets all her
business through her personal website
how I got into sex work is probably the
most common question that I get asked
before sex work I had a corporate job
around 2008 during the financial crisis
the business that I had as a consultant
failed I went through a personal growth
period where I rejected kind of material
things it was a very kind of hippy
spiritual experience so it was kind of
between growing pot and sex work and I
chose sex work because I'm good at it
Holly says she's not a victim but if you
look at a recent spate of high-profile
celebrity driven charities you'd get the
impression that all sex work is just
that victimization they call it sex
trafficking pimps and traffickers no
longer have to just you know work the
street they can just place an ad and sit
back and have their customers come to
them wherever they might be in
California the anti traffickers claimed
a major victory with the passage of prop
35 which garnered an impressive 80 plus
percent support at the ballot box from
California voters after all who could be
against punishing what amounts to the
sexual enslavement of children prop 35
was really scary for sex workers and a
lot of us came out of the woodwork to
work on it because it required that if
we were arrested we would have to
register as sex offenders in our
neighborhoods which is really crazy for
anybody who wants to rent a home or get
a job or foster a child or keep the
child they currently have because of
prop 35 if I were attacked I would think
a lot more about whether I would report
that to the authorities because of my
concern for my family Kemp's love prop
35 you say to your young girl look the
cops can't touch you if the cops come up
and they give you to the social worker
tell the social worker you want to go to
ABC group home grab a me and Heather
meet me at Roscoe's on Saturday now he's
got two more girls dr. Louis Lee is no
fan of prostitution and runs a worldwide
organization called children of the
night which rescues underaged
prostitutes but she says that laws like
prop the
35 have unintended consequences
uninformed people who put millions of
dollars and lots of public relations
effort into trying to create prop 35
where to try and shut down Craigslist or
that page comm all they do is push the
problem underground they are calling
themselves the anti-trafficking lobby
but they're really really a group of
people that are primarily against
commercial sex work whether it is
voluntary or trafficked the difference
between human trafficking and
prostitution is coercion I'm not a
victim I'm not being coerced but the law
doesn't see me that way there are
prostitutes who say that they're just
business people and that they're not
victims in and I think for the most part
that may be true for a very limited
number of people but the problem is is
when you go out and you fill out a
credit card application you can't write
down that you're a prostitute when you
go out and you apply for a job what have
you been doing last 10 years I was a
prostitute there's lots of social
isolation it's not an accepted field
I've tried to break the stigma of that
we're all on drugs and then we're all
battered and we all come from bad homes
I've been trying to work on that as hard
as possible and when people get to know
me and they get to talk to me they
actually see like wow you're intelligent
wow you're witty wow you have a brain on
your shoulders I love Who I am
I can look in the mirror every day I'm
able to pay my bills I'm able to own my
own company I'm able to give back to my
family I'm able to give back to the
world so what would help sex workers is
the Nevada model the answer perhaps the
the strict regulations on the brothels
can create an isolated situation for the
workers and some workers and advocates
aren't happy that bosses like Dennis HOF
are still calling the shots
as far as brothels go it's kind of the
best answer we have right now which I
don't think is ideal they take so much
money out of what the girls are making
most women who work in brothels have
pimps in brothels they have something
known as pimp day where pimps are
allowed to visit but the brothel owners
make the pimps pay it's not a healthy
environment has there ever been a girl
that's had a pimp they got a job here
yes absolutely
but as soon as the girls find out
they're gonna try to pull them off that
pimp and it's a dope why do you need a
pimp
you're in a legal environment when you
legalize something it takes all the
nonsense out of the business what most
people involved in the sex trade can
agree on is that keeping it in the black
market is not making things safer for
the workers decriminalize prostitution
decriminalization of prostitution is
something that even though sex worker
rights movements does not necessarily
always agree with the finer points and
what is right for our community how
decriminalization will work we all
globally believe in decriminalization
why should women be put in jail for
having sex we always have incarcerated
women throughout history for being
sexually active in the 60s we locked up
girls in juvenile hall for being
incorrigible incorrigible meant that
they were sexually active and it wasn't
birth control so we were protecting them
from themselves hear us war as we have
this right to own us - nobody can take
us and do what they want and sex sell us
and trade us and this and that I do what
I want with my body when I want and how
I want prostitution is never going away
the harsher the laws gets the more
people will do to avoid getting caught
[Music]